[Music]
i'm bear grylls and these are my 10
essentials
[Music]
some dried maggots and you might think
why would
any human being want to take maggots
with them but the thing is maggots have
saved me so many times in the wild you
know sometimes especially on running
wild on the adventures you know you
might
you know you traveling the whole day and
i'm always kind of hopeful i'm going to
come across something some you know bird
eggs or catch a fish or even a carcass
of an animal generally always find those
if you hike for long enough but on my
backup plan it's always maggots they're
hard to defend apart from on the basis
of good nutrition and they can save your
life and they're generally pretty
accessible to find especially if you're
in forests or rainforests or you know
generally even out and about when
everything goes wrong maggots they've
saved me uh many times and great
nutrition lots of protein can save your
life
and actually don't taste so bad
land rover defender although not a model
of it
land rover being part of part of our
cruise life part of our filming life
part of my adventure life for many years
you know we're operating
in a lot of difficult inaccessible
terrains around the world having
vehicles that don't break down reliable
and that you don't feel bad about
smacking them around a bit you know
because they definitely get a beat up on
a lot of these jungle tracks and i think
you form connections with gear and
things that you trust and i definitely
have that with the land rover defender i
have such sort of memory of it always as
being there you know in the big moments
in adventure moments even if it was
camping with the family you know it
wasn't always just about deserts and
jungles and mountains throw everything
in the back we know it's basically going
to get us there in one piece
good vehicle land rover defender my
favorite still to this day it's what we
use
okay so the next item on my list of
essentials an unusual one but it is
something that helps me a lot
beef liver
desiccated dried beef liver this stuff's
called carnivore aurelius it's a brand
that i kind of love and use quite
hardcore when you eat this when you
first tried it's like oh wow that is
that is quite intense but i've grown to
really love it it's my kind of snack of
choice when we're out there and also
super healthy you know to be having i
mean it's
it's well known for the amongst those
who know that liver is a real kind of
super king
food in terms of health you only have to
look at the animal kingdom first thing
that a lion will go for straight in for
the soft organs and above all the prized
liver you only have to hang out with
enough indigenous tribes and indigenous
people around the world to realize how
much they value liver after a kill when
they're hunting and i've learned to
listen to nature listen to indigenous
people and listen to the animals so if
it's good enough for them for me liver
even though it's an acquired taste i
love it
so the next item for me is a little
wooden cross
something super easy super light small
something i always throw in my bag when
i'm traveling i'm not always
particularly religious but i definitely
have a sort of quiet faith in here and
this cross just
comes with me and it just reminds me of
the important things in life you know
walk humbly try and be kind look after
people along the way that for me
symbolizes a lot of that anything that
gives us strength and helps us day to
day is a good thing
la dodger's baseball cap
where i'm from in the uk baseball caps
aren't quite as popular but my best
buddy dell who is american loves the la
dodgers and one time he said bear the
dodgers have asked you to throw the
first baseball of the season we gotta do
this i remember actually
having this ball and and covering it in
a little bit of fire paste and then
lighted this thing it was like flaming
and i threw that first pitch and i
didn't tell them i was gonna light it i
thought otherwise the fire department
will start freaking out and at the end
it all worked and they they loved it but
i remember dell told me two things one
is he said make sure you throw it
hard enough there's nothing worse than
throwing the first pitch and then not
reaching so i really gave it a full
welly and secondly he said make sure you
get a la dodgers cap at the end reminds
me of great city great times and my good
buddy
so my next essential item would probably
be a really good off-road e-bike
these are the ones i use called magic
cycles i've tried loads different brands
over the years but i just love the
freedom that some of these especially
these new
e-bikes give you you could kind of pound
the hills in a way that it's almost
impossible to do on a regular bike and
it's kind of instant access to adventure
and also they're great just for riding
around town as well doing many
adventures with the family you know
there's nothing worse than kind of
if you're a family and you're okay but a
little little one can't keep up but
e-bikes transform that next item on my
list of essentials revolution race
windproof waterproof outer jacket
you know there's so many brands out
there everyone will have their favorite
but this for me has become a kind of
firm favorite looks good does the job
really well they're not expensive either
we get through a ton of jackets always
just getting trashed or burnt or over a
fire or whatever it is it's going to
take a beating if you're out there
you've got good pockets you easy get
things also yes little things like when
your hands are really cold you know you
don't want tiny little zippers that you
can't reach because you you haven't got
much dexterity in your fingers so things
like having decent zippers and
accessible pouches and i'm always
hesitant i never wanted to be like we're
selling a sort of thing but you know as
an adventure you find brands that you
really like and you believe in if i
don't want gear and i don't want
clothing it's going to let me down in
the big moments you want to be able to
depend on stuff and these guys do it for
me
cardio miracle
all about trying to help your heart stay
strong help your immune system stay
strong you know there are a zillion
different supplements on the market and
everyone finds that kind of thing that
works well for them but this one's
really helped me it's just full of all
of the fruits and vegetables also
supports nitric oxide for those of you
into this or stuff you know how
important that is for performance become
a daily part of my life little scoop in
the water drink ready to go
so the next item on my list of
essentials is actually in my shoe
always lives under the soul
little laminated photo so it doesn't get
trashed of my family
when
i am out there in a jungle desert and
mountains and you have a few moments
where things are going wrong and you're
up against it in the uh missing home
i've always got that this photo is taken
of the family where we live on this
little island off the welsh coast in the
uk quite hard when you have a big family
to get everybody smiling at the same
time with their eyes open this is one of
the good ones and i can pull it out and
just a little reminder about sometimes
you got to dig deep life isn't always
going to be easy and you're going to go
through a few storms you're going to
face a few battles
and you're going to encounter a few
giants
and a little laminator photo of my
family
is a little bit of light
for me to
enjoy you never give up
okay so my next essential item is this
watch
[Music]
i've had the privilege to be able to
design this watch we've done it all with
ocean plastics supporting tide charities
to really try and protect you know the
oceans i think people are so much more
environmentally aware nowadays if
they're going to spend their money on
something they want to do it for
something they feel is going to make a
difference and i think you know watchers
are so personal aren't they everyone
likes different things but for me it was
really fun to be able to design one to
be able to really make it tough make it
not too expensive for people and also to
throw in a bunch of survival features
like you can do pacing to measure your
distance you can find your direction you
know little things like that i'm really
proud of it and i keep seeing it now on
on people's wrists when i'm out there
you know i saw the other day i was
climbing somewhere and one of the
climbers had it he came up he said good
job and i thought you know that's cool
that's why we designed it and people
like it and it's supporting most
importantly supporting these
conservation charities and i think we
all share this planet we've all got to
do whatever we can to
protect it and i think when it comes to
conservation it's as simple as this if
you love something you do all you can to
look after it
thanks for joining me for this my 10
essentials that i try and always keep
with me have a great day